when i think about scheduling it's a
very certain type of type of use case
it's
it's i want to think of someone that i
want to interact with in real life
and i need i have a high priority to
coordinate with them and make sure it
happens
whereas plancast is much more about
discovery and serendipity
um you don't think of i'm going to use
plancast to make sure that i meet up
with a certain person
at a certain time for a certain purpose
it's more of a
in general i care about these people and
what they're doing because they may want
to join them for things and i will use
playingcats on an ongoing basis
to serendipitously find out when that's
possible this whole space this sort of
uh
geo time social networking type space
you know where are people going where
are they right now for what
uh we're at very much the early stages
of it um
and so we don't really view ourselves as
actively competitive with one any one
other player
everyone's sort of doing their own piece
on it
and there are synergies lots of
different ideas in terms of how
synergies can come about
um you know you got the checking guys
like foursquare and koala
um which is all about where are you
right now and and
tracking sort of your footprint through
life um
there's us that's sort of the forward
thinking uh you know discovering things
that people are doing before it actually
happens
uh there's the calendar guys that have a
lot of data that we kind of want but
it's it's not in the right kind of
context
and also there's a lot of data and
calendars that people don't want to
share publicly so
it's not a one to one talk about that
context for a second
um well so people use calendars because
they want to remember things
primarily um and they want to think if
they want to add something to their
their schedule they got to make sure
that they're not going to have a
conflict um
and when they want to you know uh just
sort of recall the sort of things that
they've done in the past they can sort
of look it up
um it's not something they go to to
discover something new
it's it's something to go to to remember
something that was already there
yeah i'm really talking about calendars
traditionally sure i think calendars can
serve
a starting point for a lot of advanced
functionalities social functionality
um you know i think google deserves some
credit for
doing a little bit when it comes to
experimenting with public versus private
entries and calendars and
and trying to make that sort of open up
your calendar to more public consumption
um but they didn't really take it very
far and so it leaves
so the challenge up to people like us to
figure out what can we do to innovate
around
how people use their calendars i mean we
often call ourselves sort of a social
calendar
um even though we're not looking to
replace in any way
you know google calendar or your outlook
um
it's a different sort of experience that
we want to provide for people but
there's there's natural
tie-ins the calendars that you you
already use
this whole space this sort of uh geo
time
social networking type space you know
where are people going where are they
right now for what
uh we're at very much the early stages
of it um
and so we don't really view ourselves as
actively competitive with one any one
other player
um everyone's sort of doing their own
piece on it and there are synergies lots
of different ideas in terms of how
synergies can come about um you know you
got the checking guys like foursquare
and koala
which is all about where you're right
now and and uh tracking sort of your
footprint through life
um there's us that's sort of the forward
thinking
uh you know discovering things that
people are doing before it actually
happens
uh there's the calendar guys that have a
lot of data that we kind of want but
it's it's not in the right kind of
context
and also there's a lot of data and
calendars that people don't want to
share publicly so
it's not a one to one talk about that
context for a second
um well so people use calendars because
they want to remember things
primarily and they want to think if they
want to add something to their
their schedule they got to make sure
that they're not going to have a
conflict um
and when they want to you know uh just
sort of recall uh the sort of things
that they've done in the past they can
sort of look it up
um it's not something they go to to
discover something new
it's it's something to go to to remember
something that was already there
all right so let me give you some new
context just in terms of
that here is is a bridge that i see so
one of the features that we introduced
recently was this idea of making an
event problem
right so if you were to go to my tunnel
me page today you would see this week at
the top that i'm in san francisco
a couple of reasons for that the first
is if you're coming to my timeline page
to book a meeting with me no sense of
working with me in montreal toronto
because i'm on the website
um the second is that i can kind of push
that out to my social scrims i guess
what i'm going to do
we don't offer more granular detail than
that reference you guys
um but that's kind of there's a certain
amount of
uh collaboration that can take place
there right so when you're saying
it's kind of a backward looking you know
i want to remember where i was or what i
was doing as a reference point
that's exactly what we're talking about
when we say transition you want to help
you manage you want to go forward
yes as well yeah yeah i'm really talking
about calendars traditionally
sure i think calendars can serve a
starting point for a lot of advanced
functionality
social functionality um you know i think
google deserves some credit for
doing a little bit when it comes to
experimenting with public versus private
entries and calendars and
and trying to make that sort of open up
your calendar to more public consumption
um but they didn't really take it very
far um and so it leaves
sort of the challenge up to people like
us to figure out what can we do to
innovate around
how people use their calendars i mean we
often call ourselves sort of a social
calendar
um even though we're not looking to
replace in any way
you know google calendar or your outlook
um
it's a different sort of experience that
we want to provide for people but
there's there's natural tie-ins the
calendars that you
you already use